we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail from someone who really
doesn't seem to like hawaii
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard hi David
there's a really silly reason to call
but I've heard sillier I wasn't
wondering it's not reason why you're
suddenly saying Tulsi Gabbard instead of
Tulsi Gabbard I just noticed it in the
last few days you were completely
mispronouncing her name but that is that
I can't stand her and I really don't
care if you mangle it into a garbage
disposal but just wondering if I'd miss
something or there's a joke there that
I'm missing hello that's all thanks and
by the way that guy who said you were
ugly that's ugly on the inside and
that's that that's all you're very
good-looking David thank you listen
here's the thing I is my second language
and I've heard Tulsi gabbard's name
pronounced a number of different ways
Tulsi Gabbard is the most common other
way someone yesterday told me it's Tulsi
Gabbard
but that definitely doesn't seem right
I'm just trying to sort of hit all the
marks no my either way I'm gonna get
criticized for pronouncing it
incorrectly but I figure at least I'll
try to get it right a couple of the
times if you know what I mean we've got
a great bonus show for you today
a radio show has been cancelled after a
remark about a nice school shooting
we're going to talk about who said it
what happened
the scandal should they have been
canceled so on and so forth and I will
again say this is why it's so great that
nobody can cancel my show you could all
stop listening you could all stop
watching you could all cancel your
memberships but there's no boss that
could come in and cancel my show and I
am very very grateful for that when I
read stories like this we will also talk
about we talked about a lot of the
problems about overnight delivery Amazon
Prime grocery delivery and those types
of systems in terms of what they do to
infrastructure and to wages but there's
a study that says that actually grocery
delivery online grocery delivery by
expanding who can get fresh produce for
example could help to alleviate food
deserts which are big problem that is
very much class-based we will also talk
about a trump administration proposal
that would allow the import
of some drugs some drugs from Canada so
a very busy bonus show I invite you to
become a member at join pakman.com to
get instant access to the bonus show but
if you were waiting around for like the
real opportunity the really good
opportunity to become a member on
January 1st 2020 I have this
superstition where I feel like the first
day of the year
signals how well the whole year will go
it's not really a superstition I'm
kidding but I'm trying to be interesting
I'm trying to build a story around this
so anyway on the first day of the year I
want to kick off the year really
strongly when it comes to bringing in
new members because it's an election
year so we will be offering a
sickeningly obscene I mean this is if we
were to be investigated this type of
membership special might be illegal in a
lot of the southern states because it's
so obscene we will be offering this
membership special on January 1 we will
be sending out an email to our
newsletter subscribers if you want to be
notified about the membership special
all you have to do is go to david
pakman.com there will be a blue box
towards the right upper of a section of
the website you type in your email
address
voila On January 1st you will be
notified about that membership special
and please join me tonight on Twitch for
a live commentary of the Democratic
presidential debate twitch.tv slash
david pakman I will see you there